expansive and expensive
an empire building exercise
or the creation of a new world trade
order
it's not
a program dominated by china it's a
program
by which china works with other
countries
tentacles that stretch from china
through central asia to europe to the
middle east and africa to india and
southeast asia over land and sea through
some of the world's most unchartered
economic territories defaults can always
happen infrastructure is a risky
business a project that when finished
will have cost china and its partners
trillions of dollars these are countries
that need infrastructure at the end of
the day money will drive this process
forward
[Music]
hello i'm steven engel welcome to a look
at how the economic future of the
world's oldest continuous civilization
is evolving a new dynasty that's being
built from beijing on the foundations of
a project that is china's belt and road
initiative
fast trains are one of the symbols of
modern china and so too is the pace at
which the networks are being built top
speed for the trains more than 300
kilometers per hour
and rightly or wrongly in the eyes of
some perhaps a reflection of china's
belt and road ambitions contrary to some
other people's
misconception
it's not
a program dominated by china it's the
program
by which china works with other
countries
working with international financial
institutions multilateral november banks
so it's kind of cooperation
unfortunately some people misunderstood
this as a kind of china program
china wants to
to take advantage of this to promote its
own interests with nothing could be
further from the truth views on china
are often often mixed china builds up
again enormous amounts of goodwill by
building infrastructure these markets
are desperate for better metro systems
road systems especially in these small
to mid-size economies where it's not
easy building infrastructure but at the
same time there are some concerns and
one refrain you often hear
from from from locals whether it's
individuals or companies is that chinese
companies will often
will often win or come out on top in the
next 10 or 15 years or next 15 years the
world will invest about 90 trillion
dollars in infrastructure mostly in
emerging market and developing countries
so whilst that sum is a very large sum
it's only perhaps a couple of percent or
less
of the world's infrastructure investment
and it may be three four five percent of
infrastructure investment
in asia so it is very big but we
shouldn't
overdo the magnitude of this in the
context of infrastructure investment
in its simplest form china is looking to
revive the roots of the ancient silk
road with modern infrastructure economic
corridors by road and rail linking major
ports dry and wet to a maritime silk
road that circles back to china but the
reality is much more complicated when we
have 86 countries it's very hard for me
to say which country is not part of the
better road you know initiative and also
for instance traditionally when we think
about
maritime silkway it might be west about
but given the increased relationship
between asia and latin america it could
be eastbound or southwest bound africa
so you see
this is really an effort
to promote
regional and global integration it
started out as a unilateral policy a
focus on infrastructure a focus on uh
relieving excess supply back at home but
it's evolved significantly since then
and what we've seen is a growing
ecosystem emerge around those uh
infrastructure projects a growing number
of chinese firms not just state firms
private firms all looking to participate
not just because of belton road but
simply because the business
opportunities as a result of the
infrastructure spend the beginning to to
grow and to expand
so the policy today is very different to
what we saw five years ago the belton
road initiative is still very much in
its early stages
being designed crafted of course there
are some projects
already through to central asia and
the road down to gwadar in pakistan
but it's in the early stages what we
have seen so far is that there's a basic
idea here
which is connecting
the world to east asia particularly
china
make no mistake china's leadership is
serious the project has been enshrined
in the communist party's constitution
and rise or fall the belton road
initiative will be seen as one of the
great legacies of xi jinping's
president xi jinping said very very
clearly we are not going to
build a
garden in our backyard
we are interested in building
the beautiful garden with beautiful
flowers which will be enjoyed by all of
the nations in this world
i think the bri is central to
the strategy of china and the xi jinping
it's about the story of the rise of
china and the reality of the size of
china's economy and the reality
of the size of china's trade
china is now almost equal in size in its
economy united states and it depends how
you measure it some measurements it
would be bigger much more trade
than united states so the bri is a story
of the rise of china and the openness
of china
so in china we say you aim high you
achieve something a little bit lower you
aim middle you may achieve you know the
lowest so the chinese people are very
much ambitious but i would like to say
china would be ambitious for the rest of
the world there are 10 economies that by
themselves account for
nearly 70 of the belton road gdp
chinese firms have won some deals in
these economies but not too many they
are struggling uh and in order to
compete with the korean the japanese
american the european or the local firms
whether they're indian or turkish
construction companies chinese firms are
going to have to adapt and that means
collaborating with with foreign or local
partners if an infrastructure is built
in southeast
asia or pakistan or kazakhstan or
linking up with africa
first and foremost that infrastructure
should be shaped by the country in which
it is and that i think is extremely
important in the whole execution of the
idea it's not a china dictates not china
saying this is what your infrastructure
must look like that would be a failure
maritime routes new roads new railways
new pipelines new ports china's super
highway is taking shape moving its
products to new markets
and bringing the world's offerings into
china up next we'll weigh the risks
versus rewards of doing business through
unchartered territory
[Music]
one of china's greatest challenges in
realizing its belt and road initiative
will be paying for it the capital scope
for targeted projects ranges from four
to eight trillion dollars but it's how
it manages its money across countries
with high risk and poor credit profiles
that provides one of the biggest
unknowns
of the 70 or so countries china lists as
partners the sovereign debt of 27 of
them are rated as junk or below
investment grade another 14 of them
countries like afghanistan iran and
syria are not rated at all defaults can
always happen infrastructure is a risky
business in the
early stages
and that's why it's so important to have
the right kind of finance in the right
place and the right scale in the right
time and that's what multilateral
development banks try to do to get
involved in the early stages where
it's risky and manage that risk see the
policies are very clear the bank is
inclusive and we do not intentionally
try to grab some people into this bank
because it's ultimately the decision
making of the sovereign governments
and the door is open and we are
inclusive if they are interested in
joining
and working with other members they are
most welcome but each and every
sovereign government has its own ideas
too many government to government deals
will be a concern but again the belt
mode initiative is evolving and in its
early stages there were many
government-to-government deals
increasingly uh these deals are uh
profit-driven done not just between
state-owned firms and local firms but
private-owned firms particularly we're
seeing chinese technology firms
beginning to move into the belt and road
markets and looking to tap what is a
very market-driven consumer opportunity
and what role should and will commercial
banks play because they're risk adverse
as well but they're being driven by
policy in many places commercial banks
have a very important role to play
particularly the foreign commercial
banks because they provide a a robust
due diligence process to project
selection project screening and
ultimately of course financing chinese
officials recognize this my
conversations uh at the highest levels
uh often echo sentiments around well we
need uh the private banks to participate
we need the foreign banks to participate
we're not going to fund
all these projects but more importantly
we don't want to see white elephants we
want these projects to be viable
transparency and good governance they're
among the biggest challenges facing
supporters of the belton road initiative
in malaysia a change in government has
seen the new prime minister pair back
some of the deals signed by his
predecessor and in countries like sri
lanka a debt default is steering the
project somewhat off course a couple of
countries sri lanka is a good example
the chinese financed a big port there
but it's actually not very useful it's
not economic so now the chinese have
taken it over and i think we'll see that
in some smaller more vulnerable
countries
you know infrastructure sounds nice but
if it doesn't generate a lot of business
then it's not good infrastructure you
can see that
hamban dota port
was taken up without any
proper economic feasibility study sri
lanka
ended up
getting into debt trap as a result the
government of sri lanka
had to
hand over haman to the port on 99-year
lease
not just the port but a vast area of
nearly six seven square kilometers
around it
for india which is the single biggest
critic of the belton road project it's
also a question of national security
china's biggest project to date runs the
length of neighboring pakistan to the
port of gwadar on the indian ocean when
you talk about maritime silk road
the fact that
today
china has come to acquire
control or controlling stakes
in
some 75 ports in 35 countries
clearly that's not being done
just with you know commercial objectives
in mind if you're very close to china
then there's more nervousness india was
a great example but some of the asean
countries you know they have to worry
that there's a strategic element to this
china's lending a lot of money to
cambodia and lao it's clearly buying
friendship from those two countries and
they provide a kind of veto within asean
asean operates on a consensus basis
so if you're worried about south china
sea for example
you can count on lao in cambodia to
stick with china
prevent asean from doing anything that
china would find objectionable we are
witnessing a rapidly expanding
presence of china and the indian ocean
region in the indo-pacific
we understand
that china has desired to emerge as a
major maritime power
we don't quarrel with that
but what's happening
has implications for us
i think that when you have a rising
power like china
uh countries which are close neighbors
like india
or countries which were the dominant
economic power
like the united states have to think
about their position
and they might get uh a bit uneasy
because of the strengths
of china and the way in which china
wants to quite understandably and
rightly in my view link up with the rest
of the world and the rest of the world
now means much more than just routes
along the ancient silk road
globalization connectivity 21st century
transport and finance
it's still very hard to get clarity
around the financing of these projects
so even in countries such as pakistan
for instance many of these deals uh well
the financing arrangements around the
deals are not made clear so there are
some concerns there that
the chinese well
local governments are overpaying for for
chinese for chinese contracts the
initial set of chinese loans over the
last few years you know a lot of it's
gone to countries with very poor
governance you know venezuela is a big
borrower sudan angola iran pakistan
these are countries that may very well
run into debt problems but here's an
important but indonesia is a big
borrower south africa eastern african
country so i think china has some good
clients some bad clients and what you'd
expect is that the projects would work
out in the better managed countries at
the same time i would say there is a
tendency for people to focus on deals
that were done five years ago but have
only just come to market
whether it's a port or a rail project
when you're deeply involved as we are in
these projects and you see some of the
deals being done today they look no
different to those that any other
multinational any other large comp com
country would would would execute on
so
that part
and it's the most exciting part it's the
one that promises the most over the
coming years that part's been overlooked
port operators like hong kong's modern
terminals the opportunities are massive
an estimated uplift of two and a half
trillion dollars in trade over a
ten-year period now coming up after the
break we're going to get the word from
maersk giant apm terminals as we
continue to navigate the belt and road
initiative
[Music]
we're here in xi'an the oldest of
china's four great ancient capitals home
to the han dynasty and the terracotta
warriors but more importantly on this
trip the easternmost point of the
ancient silk road
[Music]
it's here in xi'an's muslim quarter that
you really can get a sense and quite
literally a taste of the past much of
the population here are descendants of
arab traders who traveled for months to
get to china along the silk road
it's no surprise to us that china is the
world's largest trading nation
wants to promote world trade
and we see very much that belton road is
an initiative that supports that uh and
i think that the overall goal is to
develop an additional 2.5 trillion
dollars of trade over a 10-year period
so some of these projects could be very
interesting to us as a transport and
logistics provider
and broadly speaking if the trade growth
does come that's more cargo for our
ships it's it's more throughput for our
terminals it's more uh
units in our warehouses you've been in
the shipping and the cargo business for
decades where do you see the biggest
infrastructure gaps you have to keep
building the connectivity our own
research and i think quite a lot of
academic research shows that when
transport connectivity improves the cost
of doing trade comes down and that has a
beneficial impact on growing trade so
our analysis is a 10 improvement in
connectivity reduces trade costs by
three percent and increases volumes by
you know five to nine percent so we see
a direct uh you know connection between
these two things an apm terminal should
know the transport and logistics arm of
the seafaring giant maersk has 78 port
facilities in 58 countries many of them
passing along routes of the ancient silk
road very much we are looking
and have quite some advanced projects
actually within the belton road scope so
for example in vardo in italy
we've co-invested with costco and
qingdao port group
to build a new container terminal and
we're also working with chinese
construction companies
to to build out new ports in africa
where we have some some interest in
investing together so very much seeing
the opportunities not just within asia
but along the whole scope of the belton
road to collaborate what do you think
should be the priorities in the opening
days or years of this belton road
initiative i i think it's for us it's
that is the transparency is the area
where we would really like to see the
improvement come you know so that we can
very often today you know projects are
done uh and we only find out about them
after the the main players have already
reached an agreement and i think that's
probably where the international
companies would like to get involved
more with the eu i think is very much
communicating along the same lines
and it's feedback to china this is an
area where improving the transparencies
is critical to the future success of
belton road so plenty of roadblocks
along the way but there's also a sea of
opportunity trillions are to be spent so
who along the belton road stand to
benefit the most i think they're they're
shifting toward you know better managed
countries and it's a more general
financing of infrastructure so countries
such as brazil or south africa east
africa they have vast infrastructure
needs and there's a lot of potential for
this to work out you know so if you
think of it as a chinese master plan for
where infrastructure should be that's
not going to work out that's not
realistic you know the end of the day
money is the ultimate driver here so if
chinese firms can provide elevated or
construct elevated light rail projects
for instance in india if indian players
whether it's tata or other construction
companies believe there's an opportunity
there to make money by partnering up
with chinese companies and they'll do so
so at the end of the day money will
drive this process forward well i think
the closest neighbours to china and
those nations on the route to europe
will be the early beneficiaries that
means central asia and southeast asia
but i hope very much that the links to
south asia
will strengthen particularly to india
because the china-india relationship is
the most important relationship in the
world and secondly
i hope that there will be strong
benefits for
africa to link up with the big
fast-growing markets of the world which
are now asia actually if you read
president xi jinping's
i would say
monumental statement in the
he said belton road initiative
would connect with the other initiatives
proposed by many other countries
so we in adb are very very supportive of
the bell road road initiative of course
when when we are approached for
financing the projects we will have to
to see whether they meet our standards
for us the three basic standards are as
follows financial sustainability
environmental protection and the
protection of the local people's
interests by the mid 15th century due
largely to more efficient seabourn trade
as well as squabbles between the
participating states the original
overland silk road began its decay it
was about the same time that the
forbidden city here behind me was being
completed to serve as the home to
chinese emperors for the next 500 years
now the revival of the old route is
indicative indeed of china's
re-emergence as a global trading power
by anyone's measure china's belt and
road initiative is a massive project
trillions have been spent on
infrastructure linking china to the
world by road
rail sea and pipelines
reinvigorating the ancient trade routes
from china through central asia to
europe africa and the middle east to
southeast asia and india
an ambitious upgrade which is now an
ecosystem in itself
we begin this program here in mumbai
known as a gateway to india a symbolic
entry point of the world's largest
democracy but not so welcoming to
china's belt and road initiative
two countries with massive economies
accounting for more than a third of the
global population but with a long
history of mistrust
well i think it's understandable that
india is nervous about having this giant
neighbor that's just growing so quickly
and it's frankly outpaced india in a lot
of ways so i understand india is nervous
about this
doesn't want china to be planning the
asian infrastructure
but there is potential for india to
benefit if china is financing good
infrastructure projects around the
region many of the countries which have
gone in for belt and road projects sri
lanka for example and some central asian
republics run the real risk of getting
into a debt trap
amongst india's immediate neighbors
pakistan maldives and sri lanka the
three countries which we think in our
assessment can
become highly indebted they've always
been concerned about china because they
share a border and a contentious border
a disputed border and they've always
been concerned about pakistan
so
if the question is should they be
concerned about bri
i think they'll be most concerned when
it's touching upon countries that border
them where they have traditionally had
their sphere of influence so whether
it's a rail line to nepal whether it's a
port in bangladesh or a port in sri
lanka or cpec yes they will absolutely
be concerned about it
at the heart of india's opposition is
the biggest single project of the belt
and road initiative the china-pakistan
economic corridor which snakes its way
from one of china's westernmost cities
through the disputed territory of
kashmir all the way to the arabian sea
well cpc so far to date is probably the
biggest single component of bri
it's very important to pakistan china
has not overnight but in a relatively
short period of time reduced for example
the energy shortage that pakistan has
had the electricity shortage so it's
very important to
pakistan recipient it's also important
to china because pakistan has been an
ally of china for a very long time
it's a counter counterfoil to india and
it gives them access to the arabian sea
so
it also borders a sensitive area of
china which is xinjiang province so it's
important for both parties that actually
succeed if i'm a commercial enterprise
and i make an investment which is not
viable i take the hit and i move on as a
government my concerns are not only
financial i can for example in case of
sri lanka i have a 99 year lease on a
port right now which sits very close to
india and which sits right next to a
major international shipping lane
i am also investing a billion plus
dollars in gwadar a port in pakistan
which is also not likely to be
financially successful
so i can get these assets right now
which are commercial ports but which in
the longer run can have other uses as
well
we have already seen in case of djibouti
which is which is debt ridden most of
which is owed to china
now put part of its territory for use by
chinese is a military base some of this
is definitely strategic
the corridor from china down through
pakistan
it's hard to see that this is very
economic you know going over the
himalayas to get from china to pakistan
that's really not very practical
so that seems like a strategic move on
the chinese part i can understand why
india would worry that it's being
surrounded as china builds that
infrastructure in pakistan
if you put all of india's rail tracks
back to back they would circle the globe
one and a half times
eight billion passengers a year that's
the official number it's much more if
you add all the people who travel for
free across this vast nation
here at mumbai's hub during crush hour
7 000 crammed trains made for just 1700
the system is antiquated in need of
upgrade
i see the mood in india changing
you will have quite strong investment
from the aiib which is investing for
example in the mumbai metro which is the
town city we are in is an example of
cooperation
around india's infrastructure now you
don't have to call that the belt and
road initiative that could have happened
without the belt and road initiative the
the reason why belton road has been so
enthusiastically taken up by
many of india's neighbors especially sri
lanka nepal and pakistan is partly a
failure on india's part to deliver
connectivity to its own neighbors
if you look at india's state with its
immediate neighbors with pakistan it's
obviously minimal because of historical
reasons but india has also been unable
to develop any meaningful infrastructure
and connectivity with nepal in the last
several decades the similar case exists
in case of bangladesh
where we have very little connectivity
either in terms of energy or in terms of
good transport and the same thing is
true in case of sri lanka as well
mumbai was one of the original stops
along the ancient silk road its port
remains the country's largest accounting
for almost half of all its container
traffic it's also home to the indian
navy's western command looking west
across the arabian sea to pakistan and
the middle east and to the east the
riches of southeast asia and ultimately
china
[Music]
so some of the defaults such as sri
lanka are not surprising at all
you look at the size of the economy you
look at the kind of investments that
have been made and you also look at the
individual projects humber dota port
gets a traffic of i think one or two
ships every week so it's not surprising
that the project has gone down under and
i think something similar is likely to
happen in case of gwadar which is again
about a billion plus dollars is being
invested if you're a recipient country
in bri doesn't matter where you are and
china comes along and you negotiate
um let's say appropriate terms for
whatever the project happens to be
there aren't a lot of other competitors
beating down your door so this has been
china's huge advantage they bring not
only the funding but also the expertise
to actually execute and that is a very
compelling package for a recipient
country you but the recipients do have
to be careful of the financial terms
one of the countries that stands to gain
most from china's belt and road
initiative is kazakhstan we're in the
capital astana administrative hub of the
world's largest landlocked country a
country locked between china and russia
at the center of a balancing act between
geopolitics and economic advancement
[Music]
astana is an ultra modern city built in
the oil riches of what is by far central
asia's dominant economy
a city celebrating its 20th anniversary
and a birth date of the country's one
and only president
no sultan
has ruled kazakhstan since independence
from the soviet union in 1991
seen here opening astana's international
finance center a bold move five years in
the planning to link the region's
capital markets much like his country
has embraced its role as a key overland
pivot of china's belt and road
initiative
the key agenda of the economic policy of
the government is the diversification of
the economy diversification towards
creation renewable sectors of our
economy
in a different industrial dimension but
also the services sector and among these
we financial services so we uh want to
be the financial hub of the region we
want to help to religion to develop
the economies and i think in this arms
kazakhstan in a very good track to
deliver it we are naturally the first
country that lies to the west of china
as we go towards europe
and we have built our own infrastructure
even before the initiative was launched
we have built 2 500 kilometers of
railroads
to reconnect east and west of the
country so when the initiative was
launched
this infrastructure came in handy we
were prepared and we are now cooperating
with the chinese on implementing
numerous projects there is a
program uh to implement 51 projects
worth 28 billion dollars in kazakhstan
jointly with the chinese they are
relating to belton road initiative but
not exclusively so it's it's a very
wide-ranging economic cooperation of
course one of the key
benefits for us is
that we're transit country
and
transit is a very good way of making
money and then doing business in our
country for example we have finalized
the
kazakhstan part of western china western
europe super highway which is about 3000
kilometers long it costs us something
like 3 million us dollars and that one
goes to the russian border another route
is um taking us to the caspian sea and
to that end we have built a new port in
kurik
on the on the shores of the caspian sea
and that route takes us across the
caspian to azerbaijan georgia
and then from georgia to turkey and from
turkey to mediterranean and
further west and yet another one
is the railroad that takes us from the
caspian from from macdow to turkmenistan
and iran and to the gulf
so we we have diversified our
transportation routes
and we have provided for
various alternatives not only going
north west but also going south
on kazakhstan's border with china are
plans to build the world's largest dry
[Music]
built on port
kazakhstan not far from what is known as
the eurasian point of inaccessibility
that's the farthest point on earth from
an ocean
nearly everything that crosses into the
west by rail from china passes
the chinese invested into that 50 50
with us so we have a train now that can
travel from leningan in the
east of china
to through china to horgos then through
kazakhstan
and
to istanbul in about two weeks
and we want to
want to decrease the um
the the traffic time they did the
transit time to about 12 10 days so this
part of the world used to be the heart
of the silk road for centuries and
centuries in the past and right now as
we recreate the silk road in
asphalt and rail now in still
kazakhstan again is recovering its place
as the key crossroads in the heart of
eurasia give us a sense of the sectors
that will benefit in kazakhstan when the
maritime communication came in it stole
away the show if you will now
gradually land communications are taking
hold
the industries that stand to benefit the
most are obviously construction
processing petrochemistry the products
of petrochemistry are needed in road
construction but also agriculture and
food processing already i can tell you
that the
volume of container transportation
across kazakhstan from china to europe
grows
twice in size every year for the past
seven years and it will reach two
million containers by 2020. so
kazakhstan stands to gain about five
billion dollars
in transit feed transit fees every year
just down the road from the port is what
kazakhstan and china are calling an
international free trade zone dual
cities on either side of the border a
planned strategic silk road city that
for all intents and purposes for now
lies in a no-man's land
during the cold war this whole area was
a controlled military zone the two
towers you see behind me represent the
borderline i'm on the kazakh side the
chinese side is almost fully developed
but kazakhstan says it has big plans to
catch up cargos is a gateway to the
chinese market so we agreed between two
governments china and kazakhstan so
we're going to develop this special
economic zone regime which will help us
to develop the trade hub over there so
the idea is that in the soviet union
time probably it was bottleneck and now
we're going to
kind of ex
increase the breakthrough capacity for
the goods coming in both direction
but five years after it was first
proposed on the kazakh side at least
this project remains a work in progress
some people have said that kazakhstan
will be the buckle of the belt but there
are challenges before that can happen as
i said we have built the infrastructure
we have also
worked very hard with our other
neighbors such as russia and belarus to
establish the eurasian economic union
we are prepared in terms of synchronized
customs tariffs and synchronized
synchronized
railroad tariffs so we have not only
built a hard infrastructure in those
2500 kilometers of railroads but we have
also created
soft infrastructure if you will removing
barriers for trade from kazakhstan in
central asia to south east asia that's
next as we continue to navigate china's
belt and road initiative
for the countries in asean china's
belton road initiative offers massive
opportunities where infrastructure is
key to economic growth from indonesia to
the philippines myanmar to laos malaysia
to here in thailand projects worth
hundreds of billions of dollars are
underway to improve connectivity
we can have the physical high
performance connectivity in place then
we can see that that would help spur
activities in terms of converse and
investment
this is
one of the backbone of medium term
economic outlook for indonesia i'm sure
starting next year the productivity gain
from the infrastructure that being
developed will be start to kick in to
asterisk our economic growth we are not
going into building airports and hoping
they will come we are improving our
airports because they are already
currently congested we are improving our
ports because they are congested we are
improving our roadways it helps us
achieve our build build build program
and second because it promotes
not only connectivity within our country
but also outside of our country
like many of its neighbors thailand is
betting big on the belton road investing
tens of billions with the help of china
to turn its eastern provinces into an
economic corridor and billions more on
projects like this
a high-speed rail from here in bangkok
all the way to china
the mecca station will serve as
bangkok's rail hub for fast trains
heading north to china through laos and
south to singapore through malaysia
although that part of the journey is now
in jeopardy it will also link the
country's three main airports to
thailand's eastern economic corridor
the eec
we have planned it to be uh the catalyst
so to speak of connectivity not just in
thailand but also
with
other countries especially our
neighboring countries now china and
students all of us so it's natural that
the eec can
link up with the build and grow
initiative you could practically see a
corridor
running north china south through
thailand and
to asia
all the way each country has to look at
their own interests
has to make sure that
you know whatever
loans they incur are
are affordable not only to this
generation but
to the subsequent generations the two
loans that we have negotiated the first
one is for a dam
it's a 62.5
million dollars and the second one is
for the development of a municipal water
project
that's around 200 million dollars we are
currently negotiating a large larger
loan
and this will be approximately
2.8 billion us dollars and this will be
for a railway project again improvement
of a railway project that is already
you know in in bad rep in a state of bad
repair we have set up actually in
indonesia the
priority infrastructure projects
and based on that we identify which
project that we feel we can then propose
to to be to be included in the bir the
biggest challenges in that is really the
execution
out of the 50 at the moment we only were
able to utilize about nine
so we are
still very far to go so while the
funding is there there are also a number
of requirements that we have to follow
in order to get that
other risks of unmanageable costs
oh i think there are definitely many
right i think this is not just about
beddon road as you know indonesia at the
moment is in the reform process
a lot of the infrastructure projects
that's happening right now has issues
such as regulatory
issues you know
licensing we have obviously manpower we
have
also land acquisitions issue there's a
number of also local issues i think that
we also have to solve in order for this
to be maximized
another of the key routes for china will
be its corridor through myanmar and
local issues there throw up all kinds of
questions
the country borders china india and
bangladesh providing not only a channel
to the indian ocean but also overland
west to the indian subcontinent there
are concerns over many aspects
large infrastructure projects would
incur a lot of indebtedness and there's
a lot of concern in this government over
the the risk of over-indebting the
country and passing on that to the next
generation i think that's a positive con
you know thing to worry about the fact
that we're not just going all out in
building things not without regards for
our
budget position
welcome to mombasa traders have been
coming to kenya's oldest city for
centuries the arabs the portuguese the
british and indians have all tried their
hand at making a fortune here the latest
are the chinese we'll explore their
grandiose ambitions asking whether
dreams in far off beijing match those on
the african continent
mombasa is seen as the gateway to east
africa at least five landlocked nations
including uganda and rwanda rely on this
port to get goods in and out the mombasa
nairobi standard gauge railway or sgr is
the nation's biggest infrastructure
project since independence from britain
in 1963.
kenya paid 3.8 billion dollars china
arranged the financing and built what is
the start of a rail network that
promises to open up the passage of
people and goods deep into the heart of
the continent
the sgr cuts the journey to kenya's
capital to five hours down for more than
eight for cargo transported by truck
the belton road initiative is
i believe a good initiative for for the
region
the railway link from ambassador to
nairobi
i have reservations about the price that
was paid
for for the rail link however the fact
that we have a rail link now
is
creating
immense opportunities
uh
leading to reduction in supply lead
times and so on that's what we wish for
there's nobody else who can compete with
the chinese
investment into infrastructure however
when we look at it from an african
perspective or kenyan perspective
investments coming in to build our
infrastructure are very welcome from
wherever they're coming whether it's
american whether it's chinese or whether
it's european
because they need to make us more
competitive the market is there but to
get connectivity to get our products out
there is a problem so we hope that
through bri that these markets can be
opened up not only to china but to all
other countries within bri and that's
what we're hoping for
better transport links are vital if
regional expansion is not to hit the
buffers the imf forecasts that the east
africa community will see growth of 6.2
percent in 2019. mombasa port itself is
expanding to meet the challenge the
equivalent of 1.2 million 20-foot
containers passed through this port
every year
what's more that figure is expected to
grow by three to five percent per annum
the business the potential is blindingly
obvious so far execution has been the
source of a litany of complaints sure
the containers get to the capital
quicker the trouble starts when they get
there and when the bills arrive the
government says it's listening and is
determined not to create a very
expensive white elephant
sachin goodkas presses roll out billions
of labels each year
people in supermarkets around the world
are unwittingly familiar with some of
them there are seven cargo trains a day
coming in bringing 150 containers a day
into nairobi from ambassador so that's
almost 800 to a thousand containers a
day which all used to get put onto the
single lane road from mombasa to nairobi
tremendous congestion
fatalities and so on however kenya's not
properly addressed the
bottleneck
at the inland container depot in nairobi
and it is heaving with containers so the
congestion within nairobi is hurting
business
do you use it yes
we are we are all even though it's more
expensive it's in fact we were kind of
forced to by the government so logistics
is always two-way right from ambassador
going all the way to rwanda and then of
course later on it can go all the way to
west africa as we speak today there is
no railway or roadway going through to
west africa and that can be done very
easy to expand it however when we talk
about competitiveness we're also talking
about return logistics going back from
kigali all the way to bombasa all the
way to china and we could have that
two-way logistics becoming competitive
this is so key for all our countries to
have export products and export into
those markets so that we're competitive
both ways
bitco is east africa's leading producer
of edible oils it also makes detergents
and other consumer products with
factories in kenya uganda tanzania and
madagascar
it sells into 18 regional countries
german vimal shah is cautiously
optimistic about the wider impact of
chinese investments
i think there's no doubt about one thing
that china wants to do much more trade
right whether we call it economic
dominance or whatever they have a
competitive edge today therefore if they
start bringing in their industries here
to produce here to sell to the west what
it does to africa is not that it's going
to be ownership it's going to be jobs
and creates jobs here
in your grow grab and sustain your
number one position does this worry you
for us as a company bitco we're not
worried because we don't see these goods
that we make here we don't see these
coming from china in fact china is a
good market for some of the consumer
goods with its population china india
both with their populations they will
need much more food they will need to
have a lot more of products and that's
what africa can do so we've got to look
at the competitive advantage for africa
and say fine what are the products that
we can then export into china using the
same belt road initiative how much do
you currently then sell to
china or india zero
this glass half full attitude is often
counted by fears that all this hugely
expensive infrastructure is simply a
fast track for china to exploit new
markets while leaving african countries
swimming in debt there have also been
complaints about transparency for
example how china road and bridge
corporation was given the contract to
operate the line for 10 years and there
was no tender process
beijing's african enterprise is really
based on trade and not benevolence it's
also inextricably linked to the way the
country sees itself in the future in a
geopolitical sense and beyond meanwhile
for kenya and its neighbors
they see a medium-term locomotive for
growth but down the track things look a
lot more murky
some are raising questions about the
level of indebtedness or whether or not
it's a win-win relationship
coming up we have a look at whether it
can be that or it'll be a situation
where there's only one victor
[Music]
after mombasa containers end up here in
nairobi now that's not the end of the
story it's the start of a more profound
one opportunities for new markets
stretch beyond kenya's capital beyond
kenya itself to tanzania uganda rwanda
or even europe the question is did it
all come at a price that they can afford
our leaders are letting africa go to
china that's my view
i think we need to do it in moderation
uh while at the same time maintain our
country
we there's quite a lot we can learn and
gain from china quite a lot but i think
we need to do it to some extent
not get china to come and take over our
country
nor do we seek selfish political gains
and financing cooperation with africa
china is pushing back against criticism
the belt and road initiative loads up
partner countries with debt it also
refutes claims it's aimed at
strengthening beijing's global influence
the chinese president maintains the
initiative as a tool for common
prosperity
while roads rail and port infrastructure
are desperately needed in africa
the continent's debt pile is rising
about 12 billion dollars in chinese
loans were given in 2015 compared with
just over 100 million in 2000 that's
according to the china-africa research
initiative and then there are chinese
companies many of which are state-owned
sourcing infrastructure projects in
cooperation with african governments
some do it with financing from the
export import bank of china otherwise
known as exim bank it's a state-funded
state-owned policy lender kenya's sgr
between mombasa and nairobi was 90
percent funded by such a loan
i don't think based on the quantity of
cargo the construction cost the service
cost of the of the loan and in addition
to the cost of running the train one way
and the other it is not possible for the
sgr to pay for itself i mean with the
people of kenya payback they obviously
will have to and the only way we're
going to do that is actually having to
suck taxes from other sectors and use
that to to service this loan
a further one and a half billion dollars
for the next stage of the line is
largely funded by a loan from exim bank
an extension to kisumu will cost 3.8
billion dollars and kenya is now asking
china for half of that as a grant
instead of a loan what's more to connect
the line all the way to uganda another
4.9 billion dollars may be needed
critics of belton road have said that
these countries are mortgaging their
futures that this is going to lead to a
huge amount of indebtedness which would
lead to default which will then
ultimately to china actually controlling
vast swathes of these economies
i don't think that will happen um
everyone's spoken about debt trap
diplomacy that it's a sinister move by
china to get control of strategic assets
for example djibouti is pretty indebted
and they put up a military base in
djibouti
could they get
mombasa port for example if kenya
defaults on its railway line debts and
so on
it's a very unlikely scenario because
the overall trade benefits and
that we will see emerging from this and
investment and trade benefits we will
see will supersede these i am aware that
countries often overpay for
the infrastructure however the
infrastructure in this case was
necessary and i think overall will be a
benefit to the economy
and infrastructure builders like china
communications construction company see
plenty of opportunities to boost their
own growth as well as those of african
nations it is the parent of the company
that built and operates the sgr
i think the whole african continent has
opportunities for development there's a
large young workforce but economic
growth is slow so there are few good job
opportunities right now i think they're
like china back in the 1970s and given
china's development through the years i
think africa will also embrace
development opportunities
but the steady influx of chinese
companies and workers have fueled
accusations the wealth and opportunities
are not being shared with the local
community i think that definitely if you
look at the financing for a lot of these
projects is chinese banks if you look at
the contractors the chinese contractor
so if you're looking for the big ticket
so the person who's receiving the four
or five billion dollar check is likely
to be some sort of chinese entity
and questions about transparency and
corruption won't go away
i think this is a big debate going on
whether this chinese debt is serviceable
or not and the issue around whether it's
becoming too heavy and indebtedness and
therefore ultimately it will end up in
chinese hands and they will own the
country i think what is important here
is to note that there should be no
government guarantees for the
infrastructure that's being put up
this should be done on a private sector
basis where they come in run it operate
it and finance it and ultimately
transfer it at a price so that they get
a good return as a commercial enterprise
look at it both ways short-term painful
long-term gain but the kenyan citizen
right now is carrying a very big burden
in terms of taxes
because we want to pay for the loans
that we are taking and it's interesting
that we're still taking in more
uh with
a wait and see situation
because also unfortunately we have
issues of corruption in the country
which really have diverted some of these
resources from what they were meant to
be or we are seeing something that was
supposed to be a really big enterprise
or really big project
we hoping but it comes out to be
a bit substandard than what we expected
regarding the student group really
obviously the many things that actually
happen
have not been answered including some of
the contracts that have been entered
into uh the payments of course the
payment plan and everything is is quite
clear but the real costs and whether uh
the costing of individual pieces of
equipment and individual construction
sites and how it all adds up is
something that still being questioned
and i think it's not as transparent as
would be preferable for a piece of
infrastructure that is close to five
percent of a gross domestic product the
real question is are those loans used in
the right manner for the right projects
that will generate the right type of
revenues for the african country
again it comes back to
the need for the african countries
to develop their own perspectives
holistically not project by project
on
what infrastructure they need
for what projects
what is the best way to finance these
and then to engage with different
partners whether it's the chinese
whether it's the world bank
on how to go about building these
projects
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to belton road china's
trade superhighway people come to
markets like this one in nairobi to get
the best deal that they can it's like
anywhere else ultimately no one is
forced to buy
by the same token many people have
accused governments of not haggling hard
enough with beijing it's clearly not a
two-way street i think uh it's very very
profitable for the chinese farms that
are involved in actually this they're
going to make very handsome profits from
this no doubt um
but i see
i mean the ethics are part of it
notwithstanding but i would say well
they negotiated the best deal they could
get and so as kenyan taxpayers we should
be actually asking tougher questions of
our own administrators and on our own
governors how could you
in broad daylight make a deal such as
this kenyan companies also want to make
handsome profits but some sectors are
frustrated
we export quite a lot of our products
agriculture products to the european
market but the chinese market is quite
is really untapped there's some
protocols we're supposed to sign as a
government of kenya so that it can
support our growers to take the products
there but it has not done that our
manufacturing capacity is not
not fulfilled because we're not fully
competitive yet and we do need
government intervention to urgently
address our competitiveness
secondly
the
there are
no preferential trade agreements also
with china
at the same time both manufacturers and
kenya's leaders see the increasing
numbers of chinese firms as a positive
we welcome the chinese manufacturers to
the manufacturing fold
manufacturing is part of the big four
agenda
driven by the government
and we really need as much investment
both local direct investment as well as
foreign direct investment to onshore
into into kenya and create a very strong
manufacturing hub
president uhuru kenyatta's big four
agenda aims at boosting manufacturing to
15 of gdp from around about nine percent
by 2022.
agriculture health and home construction
are the other industries targeted for
growth
just the extent of manufacturing that we
see is creating
thousands of jobs
dire lead required jobs across the
continent and you're seeing it in
increasing numbers
the innovation that we are seeing the
chinese bring to africa
sometimes seemingly quite simple
but where they recognize africa to be a
key market they are innovating for our
markets
bitco's chairman says local companies
can grab opportunities if african
leaders pull together
bri
is seen by many as being a one-way
street you want it to be a two-way
street so you want access to the chinese
market you think you will get that so i
think this is where we must look at
africa becoming more productive more
producing goods that add value add more
value to our products and really become
emerging and that's the great hope will
it happen
i think it's up to us as africans
right to make it happen to make sure
that we do it in the right manner and
become competitive today the folly is
that intra-african trade is at such a
low we're actually putting up more and
more barriers within africa against each
other and we're allowing china or
america or europe to come in you know
duty-free and i would take the all the
leadership in africa to say unite
because we've talked about oau you've
talked about african union but it's
still talk it's called nato no action
talk only we got to get out of that and
make it happen
china's africa policy has shifted now
drawing a clearer line between official
foreign policy and private commerce
beijing created a new development agency
in april 2018 it is expected to play a
larger part in government strategy as
ex-im banks role reduces it's one of the
criticism china gets a lot which is that
it is offering these loans those loans
are originated
by the african countries they are the
ones asking for it they may have a dream
in terms of the nature of the
relationship
but i do not think they are trying to
shape the future of africa
that's not to say aid and lending won't
be influenced by commercial interests
interests which some say still have
access to resources at their heart
chinese companies continue to see an
abundance of opportunity in the
continent's rebounding economy and a
green light to raise their presence
there under the banner of the belt and
road initiative
while china sees huge investment
opportunities what about your average
portfolio manager or your retail
investor can they also come along for
the ride
if you want to invest directly in the
the sort of belt and road initiative
that you can't do it directly but
basically what you're investing is
somewhere where
perhaps it's a hub for african and
international companies so as the
environment gets easier as say for
example the cost of power comes down
then it becomes more easier or more
economic to manufacture goods so that's
the story so i think for kenya and for
east africa as a whole you sort of sell
the story of access not necessarily
large minerals or any sort of natural
resources that you get elsewhere in
africa so i think for us it's a sort of
a portal to the rest of africa that's
the way that we would look at it there's
also paying for the thing isn't it i
think in the long term you have
new towns being opened up you have
people who can do more commerce who can
ship goods and also what it's doing is
moving perhaps the industrial
heartland of kenya away from parts of
nairobi to other parts of the country so
you can manufacture
in naivasha once the
planned
industrial hub is set up there and you
can then export straight out to mombasa
and what of complaints chinese companies
are sweeping up large government
contracts in africa and white has
concerns about challenges to us
influence i think one thing you got to
tell
very clearly the chinese have a serious
advantage in execution this is where the
europeans who had a head start for the
last 50 60 years in africa did not do
much the americans they ignored africa
they did not pay attention to it and
when the chinese came in i think they've
done serious execution on the ground
they're giving you better infrastructure
at lower prices and they've upped their
game i think tied aid is gone now it's
execution you can call it economic
dominance you can call it economic you
know
colonization colonization but
africa needs infrastructure now and it
needs to have it done rapidly that's
always been the problem with foreign aid
it's ended up in people's pockets hasn't
it
not always but the past was all about
aid and aid gives us aids it's called
always in debt syndrome
okay and we don't want to have that what
we want to have now is make us more
competitive ease our doing business
however
we need to make sure that everything has
a clear code of ethics it's all being
done on above board and there's nothing
that's being siphoned off
[Music]
the stakes are high for both sides for
china the mouth-watering potential of
new markets they're at large less
obviously those how to tap them and not
be seen as the next colonizer for the
recipients beijing's initiative offers a
multi-generational change china may well
be a partner but it's also a competitor
factories like this one can compete with
efficient chinese ones sadly that's not
the norm when thrown the gauntlet many
have wilted the choice ultimately is
theirs
the ancient port of paris is in a hurry
to be the number one port in the
mediterranean and in europe propelling
it on its journey its pivotal role in
china's belt and road initiative from
greece to germany brussels to london
will explore the european connections in
china's grand plan
costco is one of the world's biggest
shippers and port operators and that
status has put it at the forefront of
the belton road initiative
china has called piraeus a dragon's head
a strategic transit hub linking maritime
and overland routes
state-owned costco took over management
of pier 2 in 2009 under a 35-year
concession pouring millions of euros
into upgrading infrastructure and
building a third pair
in 2016 greece mired in its debt crisis
sold a controlling stake in the port
authority to costco for 370 million
euros and a promise to invest at least
350 million more costco cemented perez's
place in beijing's new world order the
port has been a success bloomberg
intelligence says costco was in the
right place at the right time perius
handled more than four million 20-foot
containers or equivalent last year
making it the third busiest in the
mediterranean and number seven in europe
according to port economics
that's growth of almost 200 percent
compared with a decade earlier
the port's managing director says
getting to this point hasn't been plain
sailing
this is a full competitive
business
everybody is
do his best in order to win the support
from the different carrier we can
benefit from the one bear world
initiative but another financial support
for sure
what we get
is because the one bear worldwide
initiative will create more trade
opportunities
and this trade opportunity as a carrier
and as a terminal we win the benefit
from that chinese investment has
supercharged pereira's port but china's
clout has also raised concerns that
local businesses could be squeezed out
almost all the companies in greece are
small medium enterprises
they
listen to the fear
they're afraid
that these huge companies
will take their business from their
hands business groups say initial
antagonism has largely turned to
acceptance and the hunt for opportunity
there are a lot of people that
they are not satisfied because they
thought we could also
exploit the sport by ourselves because
there are some people that blame chinese
that they took advantage of the greek
crisis
but on the other hand we very well know
that the rules of business is that when
you find an investment in good price you
go for it it's a catalyst it's an
opportunity for all of us
to start
negotiating how we invest paired with
support the supply chain and logistics
are hinderland and hitherland is where
we can invest where we can take
advantage where we can use tools
like
creating clusters
like creating growth of volumes in order
to produce wealth but the belton road
fueled push of chinese firms across
europe has also stoked fears about
china's so-called soft power reach and
geopolitical ambitions
chinese state-owned firms now control
around 10
of europe's container terminal capacity
according to the international transport
forum the european commission says it
welcomes the belt and road initiative
but with caveats there are two major
issues which we want to make sure
that that happens all those projects
financed by china and the others
should be economically
and environmentally sustainable and the
second especially course for
tender
should be competitive and open for
everybody we want to be part of this
project but
all the concrete investments
must be reasonable
and there are other concerns beyond
simply how investments are implemented
the european union in particular
is very concerned about china
trying to divide and conquer europe
through the belton road there are
countries in central
south uh eastern europe that
are leaning forward because
they haven't recovered from the global
financial crisis as other countries have
and they really want to take advantage
of these chinese offers for assistance
and infrastructure development and so
it's those countries many of those
countries that we see are susceptible to
receiving the benefits of the belton
road and then turning around and
basically taking steps and actions that
support china in other venues and in
political fora and that's where i think
european leaders are growing concern in
areas
where you need unanimity voting
inside the eu and which are sensitive
the chinese just need to own so to speak
one government out of 28 to block
common resolutions on an in a number of
areas what do you say to those
people who are concerned that aligning
yourself so closely
with chinese state-owned companies like
costco
creates a dependency for a country like
greece for greece
in greece as greek we need investments
we need foreign investments
if these investments they have come from
china they are mostly welcome for me if
they could come from germany it would be
also very welcome or united states
[Music]
coming up we go to germany where the ceo
of siemens tells us why he thinks
ignoring the belton road is more of a
risk than getting on board and if you
have an initiative good or bad right or
wrong well perceived or not which covers
70 of the global population you better
take that seriously
[Music]
while perez is china's main maritime
link into europe deutschberg port here
in germany the world's largest inland
port is central to china's overland
ambitions every week trains loaded with
chinese goods arrive here and they lock
into a logistical web that transports
toys clothes and electronics to
consumers across the continent
deuceberg's network of rail and
waterways made the city an inland port a
nexus for industry its history is firmly
planted in coal and steel with those
sectors on the decline the ceo of
logistics hub operator deusport is
hitching his wagon to the belton road
initiative it began with a rail link
from hewlett-packard's manufacturing
centre in china's south western city of
chongqing it all started at least six
seven years ago the first train was a
dedicated train from hewlett-packard
into
duisburg
and then we saw the chance
uh with respect to this turntable and
hub positioning
uh acting from duesberg to china and
vice versa
as the distribution hub for for europe
since then the value of goods going
between china and europe by rail has
surged as has the number of freight
services according to the center for
strategic and international studies with
the belton road being a major driver
every week about 30 trains from china
arrive here in doing sport the chinese
want to increase that number to about 50
by 2020 they also want to decrease the
amount of time it takes it currently
takes about 12 days to get from china to
germany they want to cut that down to 10
or fewer
a fast route into europe has become more
important with the rise of industrial
production in china's southwestern
regions cities like chongqing and
chengdu are far from shipping routes on
the coast at the same time deusport
seeks out projects with cities and
companies linked to the belton road
initiative to strengthen its business
with hopes there will be knock-on
effects for its home city we have built
partnerships strategic partnerships for
instance with china immersion which is
one of the biggest group we are very
close to a strategic partnership with
costco with the costco group they have
all
very concrete intentions and
you can imagine that part of the
strategic partnership is also an
involvement here in dispute you've
developed this
relationship with your chinese
counterparts and that opens up other
opportunities for you right across
europe our clients are
global so and and we have to check
where will be the
new trading routes or how can we
optimize the transportation chains that
is the reason for instance why we are
investing with with the largest logistic
group in turkey the akas group 50
kilometer outside of istanbul and to
build a rail port or why we are
interested in in looking for a report in
investment in trieste because i think
trieste will become a very important
port in the maritime one belt one road
link and then serving for for the
southern part of europe the german
chambers of commerce and industry tells
bloomberg many members see indirect
advantages from improved logistics
powered by belton road initiative
projects but only about 30 percent see
opportunities to profit directly at this
point there's also a level of caution
some of our major players they are
already involved but there's only a few
and then i have to uh
mention also the the the risk or the
complaints about
the bidding process and it is not yet
evolved that
we can say it is transparent it is
inclusive it's non-discriminatory
and it is respecting standards what
should be
a good standards when it comes to public
procurement tenders well that's
interesting because
in china of course the chinese will
stress that this is initiative that is
open to all that it is transparent but
the reality on the ground is
different to that
we don't have an overview where
is the next project and where
can
competitors participate if there is the
wish that also german companies that
other european companies can participate
then we need more transparency
and we have to sit on on at one table in
order to discuss
siemens is one of the major german
players that have embraced the
initiative the conglomerate generated
revenue of more than seven billion euros
in china in 2017 about nine percent of
the total and it's looking to deepen the
relationship like do sport the
conglomerate is hammering out new paths
for future growth after difficult times
the global shift to renewable energy
sources means siemens power plant
equipment unit once a flagship has
suffered a protracted slowdown so we
have a structural challenge to master
and that means you master it by
innovation but you also master it by
finding new ways of doing business such
as the belden road initiative
where obviously almost 90 countries are
being
part of and
most of them don't have a sustainable
reliable and affordable energy so there
is opportunities there those with
concerns about the initiative say that
some of the chinese companies that
you're potentially partnering with they
don't have the same levels of corporate
governance in terms of standards that
you do there are concerns around
transparency the susceptibility of some
of these chinese firms to things like
corruption
do you expose yourself to risks and
is it a price worth paying essentially
well we obviously wouldn't pay such a
price at all because it's just a no-go
i mean if
that's true for any
economy in any country
now in this case if china wants to play
an international role
as the aspiration has been announced
they need to adhere to international
standards
and should be should there be any
deficits
due to the lack of experience how to
handle it they've got the perfect
partner with siemens because we've
learned the hard way but we know it now
do you see china as a competitor or a
partner for the european economy
both
i think this is in today's world there
is not this thing either your competitor
or partner or somebody else you can be
either way depending on what value you
can create to the specific project
china has always been a long-term
thinker
and i believe if the western world
doesn't get it act together on how it
designs free trade
and how it interacts also in solving
problems
maybe china just says well i've got 90
countries
with 70 percent of the world's
population
maybe i just declared that bri to be the
new wto so you need to be very mindful
about what we deal with here because
most of the economic and political power
shifts go with the amount of people in a
country
and if you have an initiative
good or bad right or wrong well
perceived or not
which which covers 70 of the global
population you better take that
seriously
if any european company can make a
success of profiting from china's belt
and road initiative it is siemens
infrastructure is in the company's dna
and its ties to china run deep but that
success will be dependent on european
leaders and their ability to persuade
china to make the initiative compatible
with western business norms
that's coming up
for many economies and businesses across
europe the belton road initiative can
offer new directions for growth it also
opens the way for chinese companies
however as we discover in this bloomberg
special feature there's increasing
pushback in the corridors of power in
germany france and across the european
union the greek debt crisis provided an
opening for china to bolster its
maritime links into europe via the perez
port
winning over europe's lawmakers though
is proving more of a challenge
when the belton road initiative was
first announced in 2013
we saw very strong support from europe i
think there was huge amount of interest
in how could european countries benefit
we saw however in 2017
much of that enthusiasm begin to wane
you the used doctrine constantly
currently is that it has a constant
offer to china to come and join and a
constant wish to come and join and
that's even clearer at the level of some
member states but
on
shall we say our terms at least on
transparent terms
which is a condition that
most chinese projects accept those
financed by aib do not fulfill at prison
[Music]
the european commission has been working
on tightening investment screening and
rolling out a coordinated approach
across the block
currently fewer than half of eu member
states have rules to allow review of
foreign direct investments what is our
priority at the moment is to make sure
that all those potential projects
have a level playing field
that financing
comes from the normal competition like
what is the case here in europe there's
obviously an appetite in the european
union now for greater oversight of
chinese investments
to what extent is that going to impact
the belton road initiative there is a
rising understanding amongst our member
states that as
as much as we want to be open
destination for foreign direct
investments
as we are we are probably the most open
market in the world
we must know who is investing and for
what purposes there are also moves to
reduce unanimity voting to diminish
members veto powers particularly on
political and human rights issues we
have seen efforts where
china has gained strategic influence in
countries through
the benefits of the belt and road to
those countries building infrastructure
and helping out with development
assistance and then using that influence
to as an advantage for china
in terms of its international efforts or
in a way that helps china politically
for example
both greece and hungary
large recipients of belton road
efforts by china stepped forward to
block a statement in the eu that would
criticize china and the south china sea
the eu is also sharply aware of china's
increasing investments in the nearby
western balkans and eastern partnership
countries it's reaching out with a
trans-european network for transport
done quote the european way meanwhile
infrastructure builders like china
communications construction company and
their subsidiaries are forging ahead
with deals in those regions in a rare
interview with a western media
organization cccc chairman leo chitao
told bloomberg he sees potential in
europe despite tighter scrutiny of
chinese investments
we have principles when choosing
investments the project must meet the
highest standards of environmental
protection and bring benefit to the
country's economic and societal
development and people's livelihoods
we've gone through experiences when
governments change they put our projects
on hold and review them again as long as
they're good for the country and they're
a win-win everyone will go ahead some
media have different views but i think
it's because of a lack of understanding
the european union still hasn't
officially
signed off on the belton road initiative
they point to concerns around the
transparency of the bidding process
around environmental
issues are those concerns justified do
you think we need to promote mutual
understanding and in this respect we
also need to work with companies in
western countries including those in
europe if we can strengthen our
cooperation i think transparency will
increase so we're working with europe on
many projects
i'm curious how do you respond to
allegations of corruption and fraud that
have been leveled at your company
and some of its projects
involved and linked to the belt and road
initiative we don't allow and do not
have any corrupt behaviors related to
any official because we know that this
kind of corruption is not going to help
with the company's sustainable
development
and as a listed company we're subject to
market supervision
if there's corrupt behavior the company
is finished on this we are very clear
because critics of the belton road
initiative still point to
what they would say is a lack of
transparency around some of the projects
what they would say is a lack of
hiring of local labor versus chinese
labor and then ultimately many of these
projects leave
the countries heavily indebted to to
china that would be the criticism there
is some truth in that criticism is there
not
on the whole i think the situation will
become more transparent as the belton
road initiative progresses
on the issue of pushing up debt some
countries do have relatively higher
borrowing i don't think that's scary as
long as the country's economy is growing
enough to digest it
it's important to see whether the debt
funded projects are good for the
country's economic development
of course i think it's necessary for
developed nations to offer financial aid
to countries that lack development
capability as for labour currently my
overseas ratio is at least one to ten in
my company there's one chinese person
employed for every 10 foreigners
the labor cost of a chinese employee is
much higher than that for a local
many developing countries are still
catching up and their cost of labor is
lower than ours
therefore from the company's perspective
we want to localize as much as possible
hire local people and use fewer chinese
i can't say there are no problems or
that we're perfect but the reality is
it's not as people say either i think
it's because of a lack of understanding
for both europe and china the potential
for business opportunities around the
belton road initiative are significant
yet too often a lack of transparency is
stoking concerns fueled by the fact that
many of the big chinese companies
involved are state-owned china needs to
realize that the way that it sees its
belt and road initiative is not
necessarily the way other countries see
their belt and road initiative this is
very important for china
it is now president xi jinping's
flagship international program it's
embedded in the chinese constitution the
international community i think should
look at the belt and road initiative and
figure out
where countries can partner with china
where they will maintain and meet the
international standards that we hold so
dearly and where they're not
we ought to be stepping forward to put
credible alternative proposals forward
that maintain those high international
standards
that have transparency sustainability of
projects and have the labor and
environmental standards that we care so
deeply about
[Music]
europe's leaders are trying to remain
open-minded about the potential
opportunities around china's belt and
road initiative but it's clear that
locking in full eu support will require
beijing to translate rhetoric into
reality particularly around issues of
transparency sustainability and
inclusiveness
some european firms are hungrily eyeing
dividends but those are likely still
years away
i'm tom mckenzie thanks for watching
[Music]
you